clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic
merci à toi à la saison des amours le
bernard l'hermite mal trop timide pour
oser aborder une femelle tente
désespérément de féconder le sable
mouillé
[Musique]
restaurants bars et cafés pourront
ouvrir dans tous les départements à
partir du 2 juin
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est beau compliment blizzard a
été bizarre je sais pas vous mais
globalement j'ai l'impression qui a en
gros deux catégories de personnes celles
qui continuent à se confiner pour plein
de raisons et celles qui font comme si
c'est bon tout était redevenu comme
avant alors au dernier là on peut leur
dire que mon fait pacini l'épidémie elle
est encore en cours et il ya quand même
deux ou trois trucs auxquels il faut
qu'on continue à faire gaffe pendant un
petit moment pour que tout redevienne
comme avant le plus rapidement possible
justement et et puis avec le moins de
dégâts humains possibles et aux autres
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut leur dire bah
on peut leur dire que oui effectivement
c'est bien de continuer à te regarde
mais que rester cloîtrés c'est pas une
solution et puis c'est pas bon en plus
on a tous besoin d'interaction sociale
alors on a tous plus ou moins besoin pas
autant les uns que les autres
et puis on a tous plus ou moins envie
aussi mais globalement on a tous besoin
et puis pour notre santé mentale et
notre santé physique on a vraiment se
bouger
on a besoin de sortir on a besoin de la
lumière du jour
tout ça on a déjà parlé dans une vidéo
je vous remets le lien dans la
description dans les deux cas que ce
soit pour se concentrer ou pour ce qu'en
font pas assez
il ya un autre truc c'est le fait que
pendant un confinement les choses à
faire et les choses a pas faire c'était
très clair c'était très carrée et
c'était globalement la même chose pour
tout le monde là depuis le début du
déconfinement ça a un petit peu changé
et ça va encore changer
d'abord il ya une multitude de
situations individuelles la situation
est beaucoup plus complexe
du coup il veut pas y avoir des
consignes précises pour chaque cas de
figure
donc ça peut donner une espèce
d'impression de flou qui veut être un
petit peu angoissante et puis avant on
était dans l'obligation est dans
l'interdiction
mais pendant la phase de confinement qui
va se poursuivre là on n'est plus sûr de
la responsabilité individuelle
du coup ça laisse beaucoup plus de place
à l'interprétation et résultat là il ya
ceux qui en font trop
et ceux qui en font pas assez
et là avec la deuxième phase puis la
troisième phase puis les phases
suivantes du déconfinement ça va encore
se complexifier ça va être de plus en
plus ce genre de situation là donc ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va voir les
grands principes qu'il faut bien garder
en tête pour décider individuellement de
ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait pas et
comment on le fait ou comme on le fait
pas mais si on attend on savait comment
que puisqu'on fait pas d'abord première
chose pour calmer un petit peu le jeu
pour calmer un petit peu les angoisses
et on peut pas tout faire bien
il n'y a pas de risque zéro le but
en ce moment c'est de diminuer le plus
possible les risques de contamination
même pendant le confinement il y avait
des risques de contamination là c'est
vrai il y en a plus
mais le but c'est pas qu'ils aient 0
personnes contaminées ça c'est pas
possible
le but c'est que les personnes les plus
fragiles soit pas contaminée c'est pour
ça que pour l'instant il aurait demandé
de rester confinés encore un petit peu
qu'on puisse continuer à soigner celles
qui sont quand même contaminé c'est pour
ça qu'on surveille de très près que les
hôpitaux ne soit pas de nouveau
surchargé et puis globalement oui qu' il
y ait le moins de personnes possible
qu'ils soient contaminés parce que le
virus
s'il y trouve personne à squatter il va
disparaître et l'épidémie va s'éteindre
maintenant avec les tests ont tenu à
repérer et isolées du coup les personnes
qui sont affectées et les personnes avec
lesquelles elles sont entrées en contact
alors pas tout le monde
évidemment il ya forcément des gens qui
vont passer au travers des mailles du
filet mais ça fait quand même baissé
significativement le risque et le nombre
de contaminations et puis surtout il ya
les gestes barrière alors garder ça en
tête on va y revenir un petit peu plus
tard ensuite tout est super important il
faut pas se considérer uniquement comme
une victime potentielle duos
il faut plutôt se considérer comme un
vecteur potentiel du virus
l'idée c'est qu'il faut limiter au
maximum les risques de se contaminer
mais aussi de contaminer les autres de
contamines
et son environnement les trucs qu'on
touche de contaminer son entourage son
entourage qu'on touche par exemple parce
que il faut se protéger bien sûr mais
aussi il faut protéger les autres et
surtout il faut limiter la circulation
du virus c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à
faire éteindre l'épidémie donc faut pas
juste se dire je me protège moi c'est
pour ça par exemple il faut se laver les
mains avant d'aller faire les courses et
pas seulement après faut pas partir du
principe que on est clean et que on
risque d'être contaminé aussi partir du
principe que peut-être on est contaminé
où on peut se contaminer et en fait
partout après important arias aussi un
grand flou autour des masques il ya
plein de questions qui se posent ou est
ce qu'il faut le mettre quand est ce
qu'il faut le mettre
est ce qu'il faut le mettre tout le
temps l'important merci captain obvious
c'est qu'il faut l'utiliser correctement
on va être très pragmatique quand est ce
qu'on met son masque l armée son masque
quand on est au contact de manière
prolongée de plusieurs personnes avec
une difficulté voire une impossibilité à
respecter les règles de distanciation
physique et surtout si c'est à
l'intérieur
donc concrètement dans les transports en
commun au travail dans certains magasins
avec la phase iii du déconfinement y
aura d'autres situations mais en gros
vous avez l'idée contact prolongé de
plusieurs personnes distanciation
physique
impossible en intérieur alors vous êtes
peut-être tenté de vous dire bah dans
doute mon masque je le porte tout le
temps comme ça je suis tranquille qui
peut le plus peut le moins
alors dès la calmez-vous parce que moi
aussi j'en connais des dictons je vais
vous dire le mieux est l'ennemi du bien
et en l'occurrence c'est vrai trop
mettre son masque c'est contre-productif
les règles avec le masque c'est je me
lave très bien les mains je le mets en
faisant attention qui recouvre bien dû
aux menées jusqu'à en dessous de mon
manteau quand je me lève
après je me lave les mains et entre
temps j'y touche plus du tout surtout à
la partie qui recouvre le visage est
globalement plus
vous le portez longtemps moins il est
efficace d'abord parce que il suffit d'y
fille et ils s'abîment avec la
respiration donc il a une durée de vie
limitée qui est d'à peu près trois à
quatre heures pour les modèles les plus
courants mais aussi parce que plus vous
le portez longtemps plus vous avez de
risques plus vous avez des occasions dit
tripoter et donc du coup de tout niké
soit en vous contaminant les mains parce
que vous avez touché à cette partie là
qui est potentiellement la plus
susceptible d'avoir reçu du virus soit
al'inverse parce que vraiment vont être
contaminés et vous allez en [ __ ] plein
votre masque et du coup plein d'autres
visages donc vous le portez quand vous
en avez besoin
vous n'y touchez jamais et quand vous en
avez plus besoin vous l'enlever et si
c'est un masque jetable vous jeter a
alors d'ailleurs à ce sujet là je vous
propose un petit tuto
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est une poubelle ça aussi ça aussi
c'est une poubelle ça pas du tout est
alors au truc important le masque c'est
le truc le plus nouveau c'est tout le
plus concret le plus contraignant
physiquement c'est le truc le moins
habituel de toutes les mesures qu'on a
respecté
et puis c'est symboliquement c'est un
truc qui marque les esprits donc on en
parle beaucoup on en fait tout un sujet
mais il faut pas oublier que le masque
c'est une mesure complémentaire
la meilleure façon d'empêcher le virus
de passer d'une personne à l'autre
ça reste les gestes barrière donc ça
c'est hyper important de continuer à les
appliquer scrupuleusement
petit rappel le virus il est présent
dans les gouttelettes de sécrétions
respiratoires les postillons et pour que
ça devienne un problème il faut qu'il
arrive dans les voies respiratoires
d'une autre personne c'est comme ça
qu'on se contaminent et pour que ça ça
arrive il ya deux possibilités soit on
reçoit les gouttelettes à la figure
directement soit on les reçoit par
l'intermédiaire de nos mains donc on
continue assure laver les mains ou à se
dépasser au gel hydroalcoolique hyper
régulièrement surtout si on est au
contact d'autres personnes ou si on a
touché des trucs qui peuvent être
contaminés c'est à dire des trucs le
ballon qui ont été touchés par plein
d'autres personnes
on continue à tousser et éternuer dans
son coude pour pas s'en [ __ ] plein les
mains du coup bah on se serre pas la
main on se fait pas la bise non plus on
se check pas même pas avec le coude à
duke c'est là qu'on tousse et puis bah
on reste à un mètre minimum de distance
les uns des autres et puis si on a
besoin de se moucher
on utilise un mouchoir en papier après
on le jette et on se lave les mains on
le jette dans une poubelle je vous
remets pas le tuto ça c'est pour la
partie purement à la pratique qui est
très liée au virus
mais pour que tout le monde vive
mieux possible le déconfinement l'idée
c'est aussi de garder ses bonnes
habitudes du confinement d'alors on en a
déjà parlé pas mal depuis le début mais
là la situation rs malgré tout instable
la suite s'est pas complètement
prévisible donc du coup pour faire
baisser le stress d'un cran c'est pas
mal de continuer à vivre dans l'instant
présent sans trop se projeter dans un
avenir dont on s'est vraiment vraiment
pas grand chose donc forcément un petit
peu angoissant et l'idée c'est aussi
d'agir plutôt que de subir tout ce qui
est en train de se passer donc de se
concentrer sur ce qu'on maîtrise
vraiment plutôt que de gâcher son temps
et de gâcher son énergie et son moral
avec des trucs qu'on contrôle pas du
tout un exemple vous savez ce que vous
devez faire est ce que vous devez pas
faire
bah gérer ça et vous vous ayez pas ragé
contre les autres en mode à bergues art
lui mais pas son nas à lui allé qu'on
haït bref des coûts au bord du canal
vous gérez pas ça vous maîtrisez passa
donc gérer ce que vous avez à faire
c'est déjà pas mal
en plus un peu de bienveillance si les
uns à l'égard des autres vous savez pas
de mal par les temps qui courent et puis
n'hésitez pas à continuer un truc que
vous avez sûrement fait pendant le
confinement
prenez les nouvelles des autres juste
comme ça ça fait plaisir
et puis peut-être un peu plus de des
personnes pour lesquelles vous nous
dites que potentiellement ils ont un
petit peu de mal à gérer les situations
qui sont stressés à l'idée de ressortir
de chez eux et à un peu de soutien
rendre service était à il ya des gens à
qui ça va faire énormément viendrez vous
ça va vous faire du bien aussi donc
n'hésitez pas à garder le garder le
puits alors permis un petit conseil
pensez peut-être à anticiper un
confinement
on sait jamais vous vous êtes sûrement
dit là pendant les deux mois de
confinement que abba si vous aviez su
vous auriez acheté la switch où vous
auriez acheté plein de bouquins ou
un plateau pour manger dans votre bain
ou de la farine ou je sais pas quoi
prévoyez le coût pour la prochaine fois
normalement il devrait pas devoir de
prochaine fois mais bon vivant rime avec
prévoyant voilà on entre dans une
deuxième phase de déconfinement il y en
aura d'autres alors la phase iii dans
trois semaines et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
ce que ce soit terminé
j'espère que tout ce que je vous raconte
depuis le début de l'épidémie ça vous
aide un petit peu à vivre ça le mieux
possible
n'hésitez pas à venir dans les
commentaires ou sur les réseaux sociaux
aussi il ya des trucs dont vous avez
envie de parler
mais là tout de suite dtc c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui comme vous voyez je
suis encore en télétravail ça va durer
encore un petit peu a priori donc je
fais le maximum pour revenir très vite
avec deux nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout porté voulu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]